you had this comment about Donald Trump
where you really thought that he's in
his presidency in his attitude and maybe
for quite a while he's been borrowing a
lot from rap culture in his attitude
yeah and I actually can kind of see what
you're talking about he do because he's
like you know never take responsibility
for what you know you say something you
say something you know it's wrong you
all right I'm gonna do that again right
you know it just feels uncomfortable
because socially people will be talking
to you about it
right right in social networking the
Trump he said and he was like that
didn't happen yeah also there's a whole
part of rap culture which is I am the
greatest I am to speak the best I'm the
smartest I'm the fastest you know what I
mean and I I can see the similarities
there yet like look like like cono
compare himself to like Steve Jobs
Picasso yeah who else he still compared
himself to Michael Jackson Michael
Jordan right Walt Disney the Medicis
that's right I think this is a big part
of you bill didn't like your self-esteem
it's just built astronomically oh yes
yeah you see yourself like the greatest
of everything yes and it's I mean that's
what he's done really is he's doing it
so you're saying he's doing he's doing
the same thing as it well yes the same
thing like but do you know what it is I
think it comes from like like that
portion a career where no one actually
believes in it mm-hmm and you have to
have so much confidence for it to
continue to exist yeah so hard said he
just had a harder time before that right
I think it comes from like when you're
when you're advertising universities
that don't exist things like that that's
that's kind of when you're 10 oh right
oh Jesus - he was Jesus - are we talking
about Trump now are we talking about
Tonya
I think they both believed read the
bejesus
you